about seven years ago Martin had sent me
an email and he sent Brendan an email
saying this is something I wrote
something I'm thinking of doing tell me
what you think five years later this
version came and it was the first couple
of pages remained the same basically the
concept and Martin went from the one
that I read initially being more plot
driven and there was more action scenes
and there was shootouts and to be honest
with you my character was a bit cooler
and it wasn't yeah I know I know and
what's the opposite of cool it wasn't as
deeply lonely and he wasn't as he had a
Simplicity to him but he wasn't as
simple as lovely porrick I I limped away
from reading it I was ultimately very
moved by it because it is at its core to
me a story about loneliness and about
regret and about community of course and
and it has a certain existential robot
at Center but yeah concern just could I
could I do it and not be dollars
dishwater for an hour and a half was
basically the issue